[Musique]
donc ici c'est chez nous on a nos
chevaux nos bureaux notre maison l'outil
de travail c'est-à-dire la salle d'armes
la costumerie que vous
allez
chez nous c'est la tribu des sanabras
Christelle Frédéric et leurs trois
enfants cascadeur
équestre donc lui c'est perlito donc lui
il a un super caractère c'est un cheval
qui est souvent un cheval de fille ou de
jeunes comédiens parce que il se prête à
tous les jeux donc là c'est le il est
sur le prochain film saintamour avec
Céline Salette Gérard pardieu et poulev
c'est Don listo c'était le cheval de
mats Michelsen qui a eu la palme d'or du
meilleur acteur c'est un cheval qui est
sur toutes les pubs par que c'est un
modèle assez exceptionnel celui-là c'est
Nilo c'était le cheval de Nicole Kidman
sur grass
Kelly perlito Albator ou donlisto des
noms de cinéma pour des stars de cinéma
l'Almeria parc à salb est à la fois leur
lieu de représentation et leur terrain
[Musique]
entraînement donc ici c'est la salle
d'armes donc ici en fait c'est là où on
prépare les comédiens à l'épée et aussi
où on s'entraîne où les cascadeurs
s'entraînent celle Renaissance
égyptienne hussarde bride richement
décorées les équipements sont d'époque
ou fabriqués pour l'occasion mais
d'autres pièces sont en matériaux
résolument contemporain là on a les
masqu en latex ça c'est du latex donc là
on a toutes les orques du Seigneur des
anneau ça c'était dans le spectacle
fantastique alors le latex ça permet de
c'est beaucoup plus léger évidemment du
Mét c'est magique hein avant on tomba
avec des casques qui pesait une tonne
maintenant avec ça pour chuter c'est
c'est génial
quoi dé trucag le sinoche oui mais pas
que des heures de travail un flirt
quotidien avec le danger et surtout un
grand
[Musique]
professionnalisme a une technique pour
tomber ah plutôt dès qu'on commence à
taper des hauteurs comme
ça et puis même des plus petites on ne
peut tomber que à plat d'au si on tombe
autrement qu'à plat d'au c'est ça peut
être vraiment dramatique
[Musique]
donc ici c'est la costumerie spectacle
et quelques uns servent aussi pour le
cinéma donc là par exemple on a les
Romains celui-là il a servi sur le
prochain film de Jacques Perrin puisque
c'est une vraie réplique d'époque après
ici c'est plus je dirais
fantastique on a les rois bouffon
reine
licorne au début c'est Christelle
elle-même qui cousait les costumes
aujourd'hui toute une équipe travaille à
leur fabrication tenue assortie pour les
cavaliers et leur monture ici par
exemple on a les robes des chevaux toute
cette étagère c'est des robes des
chevaux qui vont avec chaque thème là
c'est encore une autre c'est du quasi
sur mesure pour le cheval aussi oui
complètement là par exemple oui
pratiquement parce que d'un cheval à
l'autre il peut être plus court plus
long plus grand
après il y a une base par exemple les
chevaliers ça va un petit peu à tous les
chevaux mais ça c'est vraiment fait pour
pour certains chevaux et on a aussi là
par exemple c'est un numéro où il y a
aussi le petit chet qui a la réplique en
miniature le chef de
tribu
a grandi dans une banlieue parisienne
mais son tempérament d'espagnol a
parfaitement fusionné avec l'ADN de ses
fouux chevaux ibériques l'entente fut
parfaite non mieux
mieux ah ben
lui lui ça fait 4 ans que je l'ai on
s'est mis à le dresser il a de superbes
allongements c'est un cheval qui peut
aller sur un carrê de dressage en même
temps que il s'assoit aussi dans les
fauteuils en même temps que il fait
toutes les toutes les les singerie qu'on
leur apprend mais ça lui plaît en plus
lui ça lui plaît vraiment
beaucoup un cheval fait entre 400 et 600
kg si on ne l'amuse pas il ne vient pas
il fait pas c'est c'est c'est comme une
personne il faut c'est c'est des métiers
compliqués si vous voulez mais il faut
que tout de suite ça devienne un jeu
pour lui si ça devient pas un jeu et
s'il y a pas une complicité avec son
cavalier il fait pas il fait 650 kg on
peut faire ce qu'on veut il dira
[Musique]
non le secret de cette relation si
particulière avec le cheval tient en
trois phrases c'est passer sa vie avec
euh
être les les les les aimer ça on peut
pas faire ses métiers si on les aime pas
donc ça c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est courant et et et chercher la
vérité dressage je pense que voilà c'est
ça à l'Almeria parc à salb tout l'été il
y aura du spectacle ambiance western et
bagarre de cowboy comme au
[Musique]
cinéma